benvenuto grazie ciao a tutti oggi non
sono da solo sul palco come potete
vedere grazie germano di aver evitato la
sede di design
ho portato con me il p 6
questo perché questo perché questo
oggetto che è stato progettato dal
ragazzo che si sbracciava prima c'è un
concentrato di tecnologia che ci
piacerebbe oggi condividere con voi
ora voglio farvi voglio far vedere una
carrellata di veroni questo è il drone
fattorino
il drone bagnino il drone cameriere il
drone per il self e un mesetto fa
durante la settimana della moda
i più attenti avranno notato sulle news
il drone modello che ha fatto sfilare
dolce gabbana per le borse in in
passerella ecco tutti questi droni hanno
una caratteristica comune sono delle
cazzate detto proprio con il cuore ecco
lui invece è un concentrato di
tecnologia che può cambiare le cose in
qualche modo anche se ovviamente la
trovata pubblicitaria e divertente ma un
prodottino da kickstarter e divertente
mi fa arrabbiare vedere che tutta questa
disponibilità tecnologica venga
impiegata per un hamburger volante
quando ci sono problemi veramente
veramente più significativi che si
potrebbero risolvere
vi faccio vi faccio qualche esempio se
montiamo sun sun esa rotore come quello
che abbiamo qui oggi un sensore
multispettrale volando sopra dei campi
quindi degli appezzamenti agricoli
possiamo misurare l'indice di vigoria e
quindi lo stato di salute insieme a
molti altri dati delle piante e questo
cambia notevolmente il mondo agricolo
se montiamo un sensore rgb quindi
concettualmente una fotocamera e o un
laser scanner con due approccio un po
diversi ma siamo in grado di misurare
grandissimi volumi con delle mappe
tridimensionali e ad esempio una cava
come quella che vedete può essere
misurata con una precisione inferiore
all 1 per cento di errore e sapere
esattamente su milioni di metri cubi che
vengono asportati nelle attività
estrattive quanto sto effettivamente
spostando e quindi dando un controllo
notevole a questo tipo di attività prima
difficilmente misurabili con strumenti
tradizionali
se il drone è equipaggiato con una
termocamera quindi poter rilevare i
delta termici
noi possiamo fare una serie di
operazioni ad esempio le ispezioni di
grandi appezzamenti di fotovoltaico
andando ad individuare la singola cella
rotta insieme a molti altri
malfunzionamenti possibili e quindi fare
una diagnostica in pochi minuti di volo
di un intero impianto industriale la
stessa tecnologia quindi il drone con
una termocamera però può fare anche
altro ad esempio in una situazione
critica una pr che sorvola una foresta
può individuare proprio con la
termocamera un disperso o un fuggitivo
o magari un incendiario che ancora lì
che sta accendendo lo zippo
e questo è possibile tutto questo è
possibile ora se la normativa enac
l'ente nazionale aviazione civile ci
consente di fare molte di queste cose
per cui non è più un ostacolo è la
tecnologia è pronta e lo è già da anni
vi facciamo vedere questo oggi ma
almeno cinque anni fa si potevano fare
cose abbastanza vicine poi ovviamente
migliora la durata della durata delle
batterie migliora il materiale la fibra
il carbon kevlar che utilizziamo oggi
non era disponibile anni fa ma la
tecnologia esisteva l'ostacolo normativo
di nuovo non è più un problema
e allora perché questi droni non sono
ancora uno standard perché questa è una
domanda che mi pongo tutti i giorni coi
ragazzi perché sopra ogni campo
non vediamo un esa core come questo che
dall agricoltore dei dati utili ad
abbattere fino al 90 per cento lo spreco
idrico o fino al 60 per cento l'uso di
fitofarmaci per che bruciano ha ettari
di foreste vi basti pensare che l'anno
scorso solo il parco del vesuvio è
costato allo stato quasi 300 milioni di
euro per che bruciano quando si potrebbe
invece sorvolare un parco nazionale e
identificare puntualmente un principio
di incendio prima che devasti la foresta
perché il gore russo si può nascondere
sotto il fango si è nascosto sotto il
fango con una termocamera radio metrica
e mettitelo il fango addosso e poi
vediamo
ecco l'altro giorno eravamo qui in zona
in zona legnano e abbiamo voluto far
prendere un po far sgranchire un po le
eliche ad un drone è molto più piccolo
di quello sotto i 300 grammi proprio
sopra questo questo teatro
abbiamo raccolto 100 milioni di punti in
due minuti a un geometra servirebbero un
paio di settimane e senza questa densità
di punti e abbiamo scoperto anche
qualcosa di abbastanza singolare si
chiedono luce macchina cioè la panda è
lo faccio per il regime dei minimi anche
per il redditometro quindi ok grazie su
astori
io nella vita e per rispondere a chi
magari posso essere più tamarro di così
arrivò avete notevoli nella vita faccio
altro sono molto più vicino a a germania
tony stark mi occupo di pubblicità
quattro anni fa ho fondato una startup
small fish punto com che si occupa di
strategie video social e mi sono
iniziate a interessare i droni con i
soci alan e giacomo solo l'anno scorso
proprio quando gli incendi stavano
imperversando il fenomeno era veramente
ormai senza controllo e tutti ne
parlavano tutti ne parlavano come spesso
accade in questo paese
nessuno fa niente abbiamo avuto
l'occasione di presentare quindi un
piano un piano squisitamente teorico
avevamo già vite molto impegnate nel
nostro intento non era quello di aprire
un'altra azienda avevamo semplicemente
studiato le tecnologie esistenti in
italia
molte delle quali uscivano proprio dal
laboratorio di giacomo e abbiamo
studiato un idea modello per ispezionare
le zone più a rischio monitorarle e
lanciare tempestivamente un alert in
caso di principi di incendio
non solo anche seguire l'incendiario
fino a casa e volendo prendere la targa
tutto questo è possibile presentiamo la
camera dei deputati ad una conferenza
stampa organizzata dall'ex ministro
alfonso pecoraro scanio che in quei
giorni si stava mobilitando proprio sul
tema degli incendi
ecco dopo l'articolo su repubblica si
grandi strette di mano e tutte le barche
ne conseguono
indovinate cosa è successo e che nessuno
ha mosso un dito
a quel punto erano troppo coinvolti e
non ci siamo tirati indietro
abbiamo deciso di fare qualcosa noi ed è
stato lì che siamo inciampati nella
risposta alla domanda che ci ponevamo
perché se tutto questo è possibile non
viene già fatto
la risposta è molteplice ma per
riassumerla in due parole costi
sostenibilità quindi e complessità oggi
se io imprenditore voglio dotarmi
digitalizzarli tutti parlano di digital
transformation industrie 4.0 voglio
digitalizzare la mia attività magari
sono un piccolo costruttore locale per
iniziare a utilizzare un drone di fascia
professionale quindi non il giocattolino
del mezzo
word o bisogno intanto di avere una
licenza di volo enac quindi ore di volo
quindi il costo di sostenere il corso
poi un oggetto come questo che non è in
vendita
noi non commercializziamo le nostre
macchine solo di componenti e intorno ai
15mila euro
parliamo di viti al titanio della boeing
questa è lì che sono in legno di betulla
per un tema di integrità strutturale
coperte di carbonio la scocca che vedete
per gli appassionati di macchina esce da
gigi compositi escono le formula 1 da
quella fabbrica per cui parliamo
veramente dello stato dell'arte ecco
15mila euro di componenti
se aggiungiamo il sensore di quelli che
abbiamo visto multispettrale rgb
termocamera ce ne sono alcuni abbastanza
economici economici qualche centinaio di
euro ma possono arrivare a 300 400 mila
euro di laser scanner particolarmente
prestanti quindi una grossa barriera
tecnologica
devo essere un pilota se non lo so lo
devo ingaggiare un pilota e non basta
perché poi il dato che acquisisce il
drone va elaborato quindi o sono un
tecnico termografico un geometra su un
topografo altrimenti devo ingaggiarne 1
quindi iniziamo a sommare una serie di
complessità e poi questo aggeggio vari
visionato ogni tot ore di volo vanno
cambiate le eliche controllati motori è
veramente un air force non indifferente
difficilmente sostenibile per il piccolo
piccolo imprenditore noi cosa abbiamo
fatto
abbiamo provato a immaginare una
soluzione che fosse sostenibile per
tenere in piedi una flotta nazionale di
piloti e di macchinari di questo livello
e per farlo abbiamo utilizzato un
sistema distribuito che abbiamo visto in
tanti altri casi di successo nel web
nell'economia digitale quindi abbiamo
creato una rete di piloti certificati
enac per gli scenari critici in tutta
italia con la rete umana con il talento
con il know how attivo
abbiamo notato ogni singolo freelance di
una macchina come questa in comodato
d'uso gratuito abbattendo quindi la
barriera per il professionista
all'acquisizione di un mezzo come questo
a quel punto abbiamo spalmato i costi di
una rete di questo tipo
su tanti servizi locali dalla cava
l'impianto fotovoltaico al piccolo campo
rendendo quindi da una parte fornendo
accesso a livello locale ad una
tecnologia che altrimenti sarebbe anni
luce dal piccolo imprenditore dotandolo
quindi di un possibile salto tecnologico
altrimenti impossibile dall'altra
abbiamo spalmato i costi di una rete che
ora è attiva in tutto il territorio e
che presto potrà fornire gratuitamente
alla protezione civile alla forestale
supporto aereo in situazioni critiche
mezzi come questi presto ed è quello per
cui noi lavoriamo e stiamo mettendo
veramente anima e corpo in questo
progetto mezzi come questi dovrebbero
essere a disposizione di tutti
vi lascio con quello che è il claim
dell'azienda qualcosa che ci rappresenta
qualcosa che ci motiva driver ii slowear
la gravità è sopravvalutata